I've just joined the National key lab of
cognitive neuroscience and learning and
also the Eddie G McGovern Institute last
year so it was my great pleasure to
attending this symposium and to share
some of our recent work with you so this
symposium named the from cells to
cognition so the timeline of today's
talk is also from cells in the morning
session and to the in the afternoon to
the cognition and what I am going to and
also from animals to humans so and what
I am going to talk about is some
higher-level cognition that is a social
cognition so when coming to humans we
are characterized as animal and social
animals we experience the most
complicated emotional experience and
also the most complicated social
interactions such as today's symposium
is also a social interaction so I'll
talk about this higher level cognition
and this is the affective and social
cognition and this this is also the main
interest of our research group in Peking
University in Beijing Normal University
excuse me for this type of because I
graduate from Peking University so
somehow I feel affiliated and today I'll
talk about one theoretical model for
expressing and a very simple behavior
study empirical study to illustrate my
understanding of the function of
oxytocin in social adaptation so we live
in a very complex social environment and
rely strongly on the social interaction
social relationship and daily
interactions and impaired social
functioning have negative impacts on the
reproduction human development
and mental health and also well-being so
I'd like to give some background
information about this neuropeptide ox
tossing we have recently proposed this
new apartheid oxidizing is a very
important neuropeptide for individuals
to adapt to such a changing dynamic
social environment and oxidizing is a
very ancient evolutionary ancient and a
conservative neuropeptide and also a
thermal it is synthesized in the Makua
magnocellular neurons in the pv and as
nucleus neurons in the hypothalamus and
also generated in the popular secure
secular neurons in the pbn and projected
and distribute the diffuse to tears of a
TA amygdala hippocampus stratum and
cortex and also Prince Princeton and
oxidizing is noticed the earliest and
notice for oxidizing is in its very
basic reproductive and adaptive
functions such as sexual behaviors and
also facilitation of birth in animal and
human studies it has been recognized
that ox tossing play a very important
role in social relationship formation
and also maintain ease for the social
relationship it facilitates pair bonding
maternal Parenthood bonding and also
maternal behaviors and more recently it
has been implicated in social cognition
so in human studies extracting is
intranasally administrated and this such
it intranasal administration of
oxidizing has been shown to pass the
blood barrier to reach the central
system and influence our cognition and
behaviors although it has been shown
that a very small amount of exposing can
internationally administrated can be
part campus
blood barrier but the amount we usually
give to the participants is above the
physiology adults so in this way
intranets oxidizing affected intranet
Nassau administration of oxidizing can
show a very large range of human behaves
and the cognition and brain function so
just give you some background
information about the oxidizing effect
on social cognition so when we
intranasally give oxytocin to humans it
has been documented that it can reduce
our individuals report subjective report
of stress and anxious feelings and also
decrease the cortisol level to stress
especially when you have some social
support like when you have some friends
aside and also give you some oxidizing
then you are a way good to go with the
stress and the oxidizing also also
increased positive social interactions
such as increasing eye contact and also
empathetic responses to others pain and
also decrease the social distance
between strangers a knock sizing has
also been shown to play an important
role in social cognition and in the
promotion of pro-social behaviors so
well there are increasing number of
studies examining oxidizing effect on
human behaviors the complexity of
oxytocin has been recognized the effect
of oxytocin has been shown to affect the
has been shown to be sensitive to
individual differences and also the
processing contacts like what I've
mentioned that oxytocin promote
cooperation or pro-social behaviors but
this only restricted to like when you
interact always in group people but not
with a group people so this is the
sensitivity to the processing
tax and it's also sensitive to
individual difference as we can see like
differential oxidizing effect between
males and females and also we show that
different oxidizing effects with
individuals with different cognitive
style like someone who likes think more
about their decision or they make
intuitive decisions so we we promote
propose this social adaptation model for
exposing according to which the multiple
functional choice as I mentioned is
actually reflecting the function of X
tossing in facilitating individuals
adaptive ability to the social
environment and I need to make it clear
that I'm not saying like everything
every effect of oxygen should be
understood in within this frame but we
just provide a perspective to look at
the simply opposite oxidizing effect
find in the literature so I'll give you
so we proposed like multiple
psychological processes supporting the
effect of exciting on social adaptation
and I'll give you an example to
understand this frame like when we enter
this this room
what oxidising do is to make the social
cues more salient to you increase the
attentional or perceptual processes of
the social cues social cues like you say
who is the one that who would like to
interact with you or someone who is not
interested in you and also when you
initiate such social interaction
what oxidising do is to reduce some
stress or anxiety anxious feelings when
you interact with strangers or increase
the rewarding rewarding experience from
social interaction so that in within all
those processes oxidising can help you
to initiate some social interaction and
to get some positive feedback from the
social interaction and we also review
all the imaging studies to show the
neural basis for these three
psychological processes but I'm not
going to go into details of this review
instead I'll introduce you recent
meta-analysis we conducted all the
studies that combine the internet so
exciting and also functional imaging
studies this resulting 5559 that is that
investigated the intronetworks has an
effect on the brain activation so this
is a general effect of oxidizing we can
see like oxytocin increase that bring
activations in the bilateral amygdala
carpet palate recorded and also in the
superior temporal regions that is the
basic main regions of emotional
processes and the social brain and also
what we can see from here is oxidizing
significantly reduced the activation in
the amygdala and also that the agency
weightless regions are the key regions
for salience a network and also for the
negative emotion one thing one may
notice from this slide is the Amika
activation we can see that a Makita
activation is significantly increased
and also decreased by oxidizing that's a
strange effect in the literature and
that has been recognized for a long time
so we want to reconcile this incongruent
oxidizing effect within the social
adaptation model so when when we do a
further analysis on those studies we can
see that the study is showing up sizing
increase increase the
Makeda activity is actually from the
studies that in that use the positive
social stimuli such as infants face or
like attractive faces and also like
happy faces or social rewarding or
cooperation collaboration with others
whereas the decreased mukhda activation
on the makita actually come from the
studies that used an active steam lines
such as angry face or fearful face or
baby crying or social punishment so this
can be an standard because like reducing
the threatening experience and also
increasing the rewarding experience both
are coming to the same end of
facilitating your adaptation to the
environment and also we an ASUS the
oxidizing effect in the clinical
population and also support a give
support to the today's model for example
we analyzed two samples one is the
patient with autism disorder and we show
that accessing actually increased
activation in the in the social brain in
the social brain well well when we
analyze the data from the patient with
mood disorder like depression or anxiety
we show that oxidising actually
decreased a mega activation so this
thing's different effect on different
clinical populations but if we consider
the baseline activation of these two
populations we can see a normalized
effects of oxidising because autism are
characterized with hypo activation in
the social brain Network and whereas
this patient with mood disorders are
characterized with hyper activation in
the
negative brain regions so Bhosle see
factors suggested the normalization
effect of oxidizing to the patient to
wrap resemble the patterns from the has
a subject and the next I want to show
you a recent oxidizing intranets
oxidizing combining a famous study after
administration of oxidizing or place
able females were scanned when they
listening to infant cry they are
listening to the same set of infant
crying but this infants crying are
labeled in two ways why is saying like
this infant is crying because he's sick
the other the other side is labeled as
this infant is crying because he's just
bored and what the what what they find
is intranasal tossing increased the
empathetic responses in the typical
empathy related regions such as anterior
insula and also the inferior frontal
gyrus through the infant cry which is
labeled as sick but decrease these
activations to the board infant crying
so this is difficult to to interpret but
within the social adaptation model we
can see that the up updates are tossing
effect on the same infant crying fits
well ways in that are tossing flexibly
adapts parent parenting responses to
infant crying by promoting the
responsiveness to the necessary need
that is the infant crying for sickness
you need to response to that otherwise
some theorists thing may happen as well
as to prevent parents from being
overwhelmed when there's no urgency such
that the baby is just bored if you
respond to every baby crying because of
their bodies your
exhausted so in this way we have a
healthy parenting patterns modulated by
oxidizing so besides that providing
explanations for the inconsistent
results the social adaptation also
promotes some predictions such as the
effects of oxidizing should depend on
the adaptive value for that individual
to have the direction of the oxidizing
effect and another prediction is we
would think stronger oxidizing effect in
the individuals who is less adapted to
the environment so my group is
conducting several project testing these
hypotheses and there are several ongoing
new imaging studies but today today I
will talk only about one recent behavior
study testing this model very simple
behavior study using oxytocin challenge
so in this study we examined oxytocin
effect on learning good news and bad
news
when learning in information we manifest
a symmetric learning pattern that is we
highlight and incorporates the good news
into our beliefs but this can't or even
ignore the bad news especially when
coming to the self and to the future
like we are future directed animals we
think more about the bright side of the
future so that's why people like Friday
because there's good things to expect
for this weekend but they don't like
Sunday because for the future although
the Friday and Sunday itself is not
different or even sunday is better but
with regarding to the Future people have
this difference liking of these two days
and also when thinking about the self
social psychologists have documented
a well-known effect that is called the
above-average effect when we have some
estimation of the future things or even
our trade we show like most people think
they are better than average which is
statistically impossible but reflecting
an optimistic bias when you estimating
your yourself or your own future so such
a optimistic bias is providing human
across age gender and also across
culture and this although it is a bias
information belief but optimistic has
been recognized as a very important
psychological resources to buffer stress
and to lower anxiety and to support our
physical and mental health so we we
tested the the social adaptation model
within this paradigm within this frame
we would expect a way they expected the
oxidising will increase such advantages
mechanism and lying human behavior and
also more specific hypotheses about the
bad news and good news I won't go into
details on this but basically we are
testing the oxytocin effect when you are
learning good news and bad news in three
behavior studies and because there's a
increased criticized on the obsessing
effect on the behavior level so we
contacted discovery and also a
replication of the initial funding on
the oxidizing effect on optimistic bias
so let me introduce the paradigm we use
to investigating the optimistic bias we
used a two-stage belief updating task in
this task we first were presented like
all the negative things
to the participants and we ask the
participants to estimate how likely this
negative event is going to happen to you
in the future and you can have an
estimation and then we give you a
feedback that is the average or the
actual likelihood that is going to
happen to an average person or to a
normal population then what we are
interested is after all the estimation
in the first stage we come into the
second stage we ask you to estimate the
likelihood again and we are interested
how you make use of this estimation
error to update your own estimation so
because all those events are negative
events so if I give you some feedback
higher than your own estimation that is
a bad news and if the feedback is lower
than your own estimation that is the
good news so we are interested how the
good news and the bad news will
influence your second estimation to see
how the good news and bad news
help you to update your own belief so in
both the discovery and replication
samples we find that intranasal tossing
has significantly increased subjective
subjective subjects optimistic bias
after the OT the oxidizing treatment act
as participants generally lower their
estimation to experience such negative
events and then we ask like well this if
come from so we are nice the oxidizing
effect for the good news and also for
the bad news and we can see that our
tossing increased your own updates when
you give some good news but decrease
your update when you got some bad news
then to further
uncovered the dynamic learning process
we examined the oxytocin effect on the
learning rate according to the formal
learning theory one update their belief
based on the prediction error that is
the large prediction error will predict
a large learning and the prediction
error here is calculated as a difference
between your own estimation and the
feedback I give to you and the update is
calculated as the difference between the
twos the estimates and the first
reversal of all we can see that subjects
learn much more on the good news and
display sable indicating that extra
participants actually learn a lot better
for the good news than the bad news and
more moreover we see distinguish
oxidizing effect on learning the good
news and the bad news we see ox tossing
increase your learning tendency to the
good news but has no effect on the bad
news learning so because there the
learning occurs based on the estimation
error which is the difference between
your own estimation and the feedback so
we further married the you're like what
Xiao Hong has mentioned the
metacognition we asked participants to
do a metacognition on their estimation
and also a second order of the feedback
that is how confident you are on your
own
estimation and also how would you accept
how much would you accept as a feedback
I gave it to you so that we can
dissociate the different cognitive
processes involved in this learning
process so what we find is that
oxidizing
increase the participants acceptance of
the good news but has no effect on the
bad news acceptance and for the
confidence we can see that there's a
general effect of our tossing to
increase your confidence for the second
time that is the difference between the
confidence before the first time and
second time moreover our sizing has had
increased to a large degree of the when
you got some good news
you got really confident on your own
estimation so besides the prediction of
this one we also predict a stronger
oxidizing effect in the individuals who
is less adapted to the social
environment in that in this case we
defined the less adapted in individuals
those ones who are more depressed or
anxious because the optimistic bias is
highly correlated with the symptoms
related to depression and anxiety and
what we can see here is indeed we find
individuals depressive symptom and also
their anxiety trait modulated the effect
of oxytocin on the optimistic bias we
show that our tossing effect are only
observed in the individuals who have
higher score in the depressive symptom
or have a higher score in the anxiety
trait but if we look at the individuals
who have lower anxiety or lower anxiety
or depressive symptoms there's actually
no oxidizing effect so we have seen for
many times the normalization effects of
oxidizing as mentioned as mentioned
above the normalization of the abnormal
activation for the patient to resemble
there has a controls and also as
mentioned this this task this results if
we take another perspective we can see
under place Abel there's increased
optimist belief updating towards the bad
news increasing ways the depressive
symptom and also the the anxiety trait
but what oxidising do is diminish the
relationship between the depressive and
treat anxiety and also the learning
updating towards the bad news such that
by normalizing the hyper updating upon
the bad news in those who have higher
score so but all of those are related to
the like the patient and also this trait
of those are related to the clinical
side so our recent work has showed this
normalization effect also in non
clinical related aspects in this study
we are interested in the division of
resources so Contra balance between the
benefits to your own self and to other
people is actually a very fundamental
decision to make for everyone thus we
conducted this famil article a famous
study to reveal the neuro computational
mechanism underlying the effect of
social of obsession effect on social
value representation so specifically we
are interested in how accessing
influences the computations involved in
the representation of the self interest
and other interest in two groups of
individuals one is pro-social group who
consider others in interest in the first
place
and the other group is selfish
individuals who consider the one one's
own benefits in the first place so I
won't go into details of this study it's
just that in the world preparing the
data analysis and also the menu the
paper but basically we find that a
social space that framed by the
self-interest and other interest is
constructed based on subjective specific
angle points which is where aligned with
individual social value orientation and
those are in encoded in the amygdala and
also VTA activity listens up so we can
see here the the blue bar is the basic
is the baseline differences between the
pro-social and the selfish individuals
and what we demonstrated the oxytocin
effect that normalization effect of our
tossing on this process is making the
selfish individuals less egocentric and
making the pro-social individuals less
occurs LLO centric by increasing omega
activate mcgraw and Veit VTA activation
but decreasing that in the pro-social
behavior individuals so we can see even
in this decision-making task a
normalization effect about starting
between different types of individual
can be also seen so all the studies I
mentioned land further support for the
social adaptation model and our group
would go further along this line by
considering Demento dissolve the mental
disorder computational modeling and also
its relation its relationship to other
molecules in this
so coming to the end I'd like to thank
my collaborators and also the graduate
students in the same lab at peaking at
Beijing Normal University and thank you
for your attention
[Applause]